There's a few answers to where are all the circles, but the shortest and
simplest is that they're simply on the page.
If we do a D3 select all circle, we can see that it returns an array
of 836 elements that correspond to circles.
SVG ones.
When I hover however, notice that the circles show up at
pixel zero by one in the top left of the screen.
If you actually inspect the DOM, you'll see that they are indeed there.
So our data bind in append has correctly worked.
It appended 836 circles to our webpage which are bound to data.
And again, if I access one of those circles, let's just get the first one, so
select all circles, get the internal array and then get the first circle.
It returns to us a circle DOM element.
But remember when we did data binding,
I told you that every element with bound data has an __data_.
And as you can see here, by accessing the .__data__
attribute of the first circle SVG object,
you get returned a JavaScript object with all the data that's been bound to it.